Stop skipping breakfast.
Or, you should skip breakfast?
We've all heard that breakfast is the
most important meal of the day.
But some actors and
athletes like Terry Crews
are adamant about not eating breakfast.
So who's right?
Is breakfast good or bad?
I stopped eating breakfast
for two weeks to find out.
I can't eat anything before
12, when I have lunch.
For as long as I can remember,
I've had breakfast every single morning.
But, I also know a lot of
people who don't eat breakfast.
And that works great for them.
To be honest, I don't think
it's going to go very well
because I'll be awake from
six all the way until noon,
a full six hours without
eating a single thing.
It's a lot different than what I'm used to
and it might be really
hard, especially at first.
Half of you are probably typing a comment
about how you never eat breakfast.
But making a change to your
daily routine isn't easy.
And I wanted to find out if my life
was better or worse without breakfast.
Today was my first day
not eating breakfast.
And I've got to say, it went pretty well.
I was surprised to find out that
when I woke up, I wasn't that hungry.
I made coffee, made lunch for the day,
and still wasn't feeling
like I needed breakfast.
I stayed pretty busy.
It was already noon and I had
barely craved any food at all.
I don't want to jinx it,
but I'm feeling pretty
optimistic for the week.
So it's Wednesday.
It's been three days of no breakfast.
And I've got to say, it's
getting a little bit harder.
So yeah, it wasn't going well.
I feel like every day around 10:30 or 11,
I get really hungry.
My stomach starts to
growl and I start seeing
or smelling food around the
office that other people have.
And it's a lot more challenging
than when I first wake up.
And I know it's like okay,
that's not actually a problem.
But if you're someone
who's trying to diet,
trying to eat less, trying to snack less,
it can be really challenging when you have
a lot of options around the office
that can be really quick or convenient.
I've actually amassed kind of a
large store of snacks at my desk,
all of the stuff I can't
eat until after lunch.
And then I'm like "Oh,
you can't even eat that."
And it just kind of sits
there and stares back at me.
I think I can make it through the week,
but I am a little worried
about the weekend.
Waking up at 6 a.m. and not eating
until 12 is such a long time.
Why do I need breakfast when so
many people can live without it?
What's actually going on here?
I spoke with Dr. Peterson,
a scientist at the University
of Alabama, to find out.
So what I think has happened
in breakfast skipping and why
it's so confusing is there's
actually not one way to
necessarily skip breakfast.
You actually have better blood
sugar control in the morning
and you digest your food a
little faster in the morning,
as well as you burn very slightly
more calories when you eat in the morning.
So all this evidence
kind of points towards
the morning as being optimal for eating.
So if the morning is the
optimal time for eating,
is skipping breakfast hurting me?
Was this whole challenge pointless?
On the flip side, we
have also learned over
the past decade that it looks like having
extended bouts of fasting
is good for your health.
What's really interesting is
that you have hunger hormones.
And these hunger hormones adapt to
whatever you usually do or to your habits.
What this means in the short-term,
if you don't normally skip breakfast
and then you suddenly skip breakfast,
you have to overcome that inertia
of changing your hunger hormone patterns.
Because your hunger hormone says "Okay,
well you usually eat breakfast.
And now you're going to skip it,
so I'm going to make you very hungry."
Any time you have a regular
eating pattern and change that,
regardless of what
eating pattern you're on,
you will have an initial barrier
where it's quite difficult
in the beginning and
then over time you adapt.
Maybe my new routine is
worse than my old one.
It's been about a week and a half.
And I've gotta say, it's getting easier.
I thought not having breakfast on
the weekend was going to be a nightmare.
But it was actually a lot easier
because I woke up later and
didn't have as much time
between waking up and noon
as I do on the workday.
But I do still miss breakfast.
I just enjoy breakfast and
eating something in the morning.
Even if I'm not super hungry,
I think I'll still miss that aspect.
The whole thing has really made me
wonder how much breakfast matters.
It kind of feels like
breakfast was just the routine.
It was just my norm.
So that's what I liked and
that's what I was used to.
After a week and a half
of not eating breakfast,
it started to seem like I was finally
getting used to my new routine.
Maybe I could turn into someone
who never eats breakfast.
But I wouldn't count on it.
It's finally Friday.
And tomorrow I can have
breakfast once again.
After two weeks, I've
realized that I can go
without eating breakfast
and still survive.
But I miss breakfast.
Not eating before 12 was really tough,
especially with all the
food around the office.
And it definitely brought down
my mood throughout the day.
But I never really felt a
big change in my productivity
or even my energy levels
before or after lunch.
And my weight stayed pretty much the same.
Breakfast isn't bad for you,
but it's also not essential.
You should do what fits best for
your dietary needs and your routine.
I no longer feel helpless
without breakfast
and I'm able to create a routine
that fits my schedule and my daily needs.
Before I started this challenge,
I loved breakfast and I thought
I needed it to start my day.
Now I don't really feel that way.
I still like breakfast and
will continue to eat it,
but I don't feel that reliance
on it like I used to have.
So it turns out you can skip breakfast.
But Dr. Peterson pointed out that
instead of skipping breakfast,
it's better to shorten the window
of time for meals each day.
Two broad types of meal timing approaches
that we have found to be beneficial.
One is the daily
intermittent fasting approach
where you're eating in
a narrow time period.
And it looks like probably
eating in the middle of the day,
say from 10 a.m. to 6 p.m.
is also good for your health.
There is a lot of evidence
that even if you can't
change the timing of
breakfast, lunch, and dinner,
if you at least make your
largest meals earlier,
be breakfast and or lunch,
that you can still get a
lot of benefits from that.
Some people love eating breakfast.
And good for them.
But don't let someone try and tell you
that you're throwing the day
away if you skip breakfast.
The most important meal of the day
depends on who's eating it.
Now this is how breakfast should be.